bien merci de votre présence nous venons
de terminer 1hure de de travail du
comité de campagne avec les membres du
comité de campagne nous sommes en ordre
de bataille pour préparer cette campagne
des législatives nous n'avons pas perdu
temps depuis le soir du premier tour des
élections législatives je veux d'abord
remercier nos amis et partenaires de
l'UDI qui ont à nos côtés depuis 15
jours mis en place la confirmation de la
préparation de l'accompagnement de la
sélection de nos candidats qui
s'inscriront dans la logique
d'accompagnement du renouvellement des
visage des hommes des femmes ancrés dans
leur territoire et qui porteront les
couleurs majorité pour la France union
de la droite et du centre qui sera à la
fois l'étiquette et le slogan de nos
candidats puisque le projet politique
dans les 4 semaines qui viennent c'est
effectivement de donner une majorité
pour la France sur la base de nos
valeurs de nos engagements de nos
convictions et sur la base du projet
c'est le deuxième point puisque dans le
même esprit d'unité d'union et en même
temps de se projeter vers l'avant au
lendemain de l'élection du président
Macron auquel nous avons adressé nos
félicitations républicaines et auxquel
nous souhaitons naturellement bonne
chance dans la mission élevée qui est la
sienne mais pour cela nous nous sommes
mis en situation d'offrir un projet qui
réponde aux aspirations exprimées par
les Français au soir du premier tour
notre analyse politique n'est pas la
lecture du choir des résultats du second
tour mais bien la réalité d'un pays
fruré comme jamais avec qu blocs à 20 %
et qui justifie pleinement que nous
ayons corrigé amendé améliorer enrichi
en quelque sorte être en phase avec les
attentes des Français ce projet il ne
sera donc pas le projet porté par notre
candidat François Fillon auquel nous
rendre hommage également pour son
courage la ténacité et la manière dont
il a créé les conditions d'une attention
autour d'une volonté d'une alternance
sans équivoque et puis d'un changement
en profondeur de notre société notamment
sur le plan économique
sur le plan social sur le plan de la
restauration de l'autorité de l'État sur
le plan du réarmement de l'État sur le
plan de la cohésion sociale sur le plan
de l'équilibre des territoire et la
mission a été confiée à Eric vert avec
les représentants de l'UDI pendant
plusieurs jours pour à la fois aboutir à
la synthèse qui on doit la vérité de le
reconnaître n'a pas été faite au
lendemain de la primaire des positions
équilibrées avec un message est le plus
important puisque la priorité est à la
fois sur l'autorité de l'État et l'autre
priorité et sur l'économie et le social
donc la synthèse portera Eric vert le
présentera devant vous dans quelques
instants autour d'une augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat des Français notamment
les classes moyennes qui ont été
massacré au cours de ce quinquena de
François Hollande pour laquelle Immanuel
Macron dans les responsabilités qui
étaient les siennes a naturellement sa
part de responsabilité et d'une baisse
des impôts nous rentrerons dans le
détail dans quelques instants autour de
cela le même esprit de synthèse nous a
animé pour proposer justement de garder
la vélocité l'énergie du projet de notre
candidat et en même temps d'avoir un
projet de rassemblement et qui aura
entendu clairement le message des
Français sur la méthode de campagne
Christian Jacob que je salue qui anime
le comité de campagne autour de Bernard
accoyet présentera immédiatement la mise
en
mouvement énergique et et vigoureux pour
les 4 semaines car c'est une campagne
qui va être très courte elle est
extraordinairement rapide donc dès
demain nous serons sur le terrain après
avoir présenté le projet nous le
déclinons et il y aura tout un rythme de
grands meetings régionaux et puis le
déploiement de nos orateurs nationaux
qui se compte parmi le visage du bureau
politique de notre formation ainsi que
les représentants donnés par l'UDI et
puis il y aura une structuration de
l'organisation de campagne notamment
pour la presse et les médias et pour les
génistes que vous êtes avec toutes les
fenêtres disponibles d'intervention de
débat d'expression et puis en fonction
du rythme qui sera proposé aussi par la
nouvelle organisation gouvernementale et
les textes qui seront proposés avec une
série de porte-parole que salue et qui
vous seront présentés par Christian
Jacob je cède la parole à présent à
Bernardet à l'issue nous serons à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions